As you add more sites to Burps with Enterprise Edition, you may find it useful to organise
those sites into folders.
For example, you could group your sites based on their physical location.
Each folder has its own dashboard, enabling you to view aggregated charts and stats for
all the sites in the folder.
You can also use folders to restrict access to sites, to make sure that users can only
access data for sites that are relevant to them.
You can manage your folders and subfolders using the site tree located at the sites page.
To create a new folder, navigate to the sites page and select New Folder.
Give your folder a name.
If desired, you can also add this to an existing folder.
Otherwise it'll be entered under the root folder.
If you want to add an individual site to a folder, navigate to your sites page.
Select the site you want to add.
Click Details and then Edit.
Under the Site Details section, we can select a folder from the drop-down list.
Then we scroll down and click Save.
Now the site has been added to our specified folder.
If you wish to move sites and folders in bulk, we can navigate to the sites page.
Select the checkbox for the sites that we want to move.
In the pop-up menu, select Move.
We can then select the folder we want to move the sites to.
If we don't select a folder, they'll remain under the root folder.
Now we can see our sites have been moved to our specified folder.
If you need to delete sites and folders, you can select the trash icon next to the respective
site or folder.
If we need to do this in bulk, again we can use the checkboxes to select the sites or folders
we want to delete and in the pop-up menu, select Delete.
Thank you.